it was a fourth security council session
held on ukraine since russia launched
its invasion
but the first one called by russia
itself moscow claiming that ukraine
supported by the us is developing
biological weapons
and the russian ambassador attempting to
preempt the denials he said he was
expecting
me
i can foresee what the reaction will be
from our western colleagues who i'm sure
are going to be saying now that all of
this information is fake and russian
propaganda but this is self-delusion the
un was direct in its assessment of the
allegation
i am aware of media reports regarding
allegations of biological weapons
programs
the united nations is not aware of any
biological weapons programs
the reaction of several members was
incredulous
i will say this once
ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories supported by the
united states
absolutely everything we have been
hearing from russia regarding ukraine
has been false fabricated or distorted
the british ambassador described the
russian claims as baseless conspiracy
theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
china was the only security council
member to offer a modicum of support to
russia's claims
and the ukrainian ambassador argued that
russia had made a mistake in calling for
the meeting
by calling this meeting
the aggressor state
has shoot itself in foot once again
the meeting was opened with a briefing
by the un's political and peace building
chief
and she referenced credible reports of
russia's use of cluster bombs in
civilian areas strikes at hospitals and
the deaths of hundreds of men women and
children the meeting russia called to
highlight its allegations
became instead a scathing indictment of
its actions during the invasion
mike hanna al-jazeera united nations